Bueno un saludo efectivamente faltan dos
días para las elecciones el día de hoy
los candidatos no tienen ningún acto
pensado dentro de campaña pero como
ustedes muy bien Dice durante esta noche
Pues será la última oportunidad para
tener exposición nacional dentro del
debate en un estudio para la revista
bella lo que mostró Es que 11% de los
votantes Aún se consideran volátiles 5%
de ellos que concretamente no han
decidido porque candidato van a optar y
un 6% que van a ser un cambio en su voto
respecto a Lula o bolsonaro pensando en
la primera vuelta de esta cantidad de
votos volátiles digamos la mayoría se
concentran en tres estados que son nueve
Minas gerais Río de Janeiro y donde
nosotros nos encontramos en Sao Paulo
que además es el colegio electoral es
más grande de todo el país mientras que
bolsonaro ha concentrado estos últimos
días en lograr captar 6,2 millones de
votos que le hacen falta Pues el equipo
de Lula lo que ha intentado es invitar a
la gente a que salga a votar en segunda
vuelta especialmente aquellos que no
salieron a votar en primera sin embargo
teóricamente nos dicen las elecciones es
que en segunda vuelta baja la
participación de la ciudadanía y bien
otro dato que podríamos tener en cuenta
muy importante es que las mujeres
podrían ser muy decisivas especialmente
las mujeres afrodescendientes en
condición de pobreza esto en un contexto
de pandemia que trabajo pues a más de 30
millones de ciudadanos a una situación
de empobrecimiento y bajo el gobierno de
Jair bolso Así es Ángela y la justicia
también se pronunció ya ante el pedido
de ambas campañas de ocupar la avenida
paulista en Sao Paulo el día de la
elección que dijo
claro lo que pasa es que el tribunal de
Sao Paulo tuvo que tomar una decisión
porque los bolsonaristas habían pedido
con antelación acompañar digamos toda la
jornada electoral es de Yahir bolsonaro
aquí en la pausa donde nos encontramos
que es la vía más grande y más famosa de
Sao Paulo y también la más emblemática
después de ellos llegaron peticiones de
los lulistas y la ley no permite que dos
grupos Opuestos se manifiesten al mismo
tiempo en la paulista precisamente para
evitar episodios de violencia así que
pues bueno en la decisión es un revés
para los bolsonaristas porque lo que el
tribunal ha decidido es que solamente el
colectivo que pertenezca al candidato
ganador podrá manifestar en la paulista
y solo podrá hacerlo a partir de las de
20 horas y 30 después es de que cierren
los colegios electorales para evitar que
haya confusiones y desórdenes ahora lo
que todos se preguntan es que va a pasar
con los bolsonaristas pues dado que
bolsonaro ha insinuado en varias
oportunidades corrupción en el sistema
electoral y lo que se teme es que pueda
llamar a sus electores a manifestarse de
manera violenta si es que no llega a
vencer este segundo turno en Brasil de
momento lo que yo les puedo contar es
que para el día de mañana Se espera que
bolsonaro cierre su Campaña en Minas
gerais y Lula permanecerá aquí en Sao
Paulo donde va a ser una caminada por
esta vía paulista y pues estaremos
cubriendo por supuesto